zoos have changed out of all recognition
there are quite a lot of different
species around the planet which we
wouldn't have today if it wasn't for
zoos
first
[Music]
all through history we've seen royal
families of powerful people Emperors
have collections of animals the king who
is a good Hunter was probably a good
warrior probably protect his people
killing a lion or a bear was a big deal
but bring them back alive when it showed
even more power virtually all the
history of Zeus is about human control
of Nature and it was a way of showing
off Queen Charlotte herth gift to
everybody that she liked was to give
them a kangaroo
and eventually we get the first modern
Zoo opening in London in 1828
to be able to suddenly see a giraffe for
the first time he probably was
absolutely bonkers
[Music]
wasn't really an appreciation of animals
needing certain things to have a good
life so you would see them in Barren
boxes effectively just as you would see
a specimen a natural history museum the
story was here's an object divorced from
habitat divorce from Evolution his name
is by the way knucklehead knucklehead
was a rule that tapers are rather stupid
and unintelligent animals were thought
of as basically automatized just
responding in a reflexive manner with no
feelings of pain or any kind of
emotional depth but that's really
shifted now there's much more of an
understanding that we really need to
look at their own type of intelligence
and how they live in their world
[Music]
the school children that come here to
the Wildlife Park all of them go away
learning the messages that we know for
sure are going to make a true difference
to the animals back out into the wild
the biggest threat to Wildlife comes
from people and most people live in
cities so zoos are very important
because they provide an educational
opportunity for people to learn about
what the impacts of their daily
activities are in Far Away places
The Zoo by becoming a public attraction
if it's done properly it seems to me
like a pretty good idea the animals have
a good life people enjoy it they learn
something hopefully they get involved in
conservation
pretty much all good zoos throughout the
world are participators or they help to
support and fund a whole host of
Institute conservation programs and if
it wasn't for those programs the world
would be looking very different right
now
foreign
[Music]
populations of animals are Insurance
populations certain species due to
what's going on the planet at the moment
the only way that we can stop them from
going extinct will be to bring them into
captivity as we learn to adapt to things
like climate change we are going to see
an increasing role for zoos
you can visit zoos all over the world
that are just awful you know they're as
bad as they were in the 1920s in the US
they don't have very strict Animal
Welfare laws people can have animals in
their back garden and call it a zoo
there are more pet tigers in the U.S
than there are tigers in the wild the
legislation doesn't permit that kind of
thing here in the UK but you can get bad
zoos anywhere
those are all signs that they're missing
out on some important aspect of how they
live in the wild the complexity of
providing a good life for some of these
animals that's actually really really
difficult
there is some evidence that people will
know more facts about a particular
animal for example but follow-up studies
to see if they've actually changed their
behavior to benefit conservation there's
not much evidence to suggest that is
happening
the official statistics show that four
percent of Revenue goes back into
conservation I mean that's minimal it's
very small and what do you find in these
big cats and elephants and zebra and
things that don't get released back into
the wild so if you want to save the
Condor then you can have an in-situ
conservation program that's based in the
country where they come from
most five year olds are experts in
dinosaurs they've never met one or seen
one the Fascinations there and I think
the same can be harnessed with animals
there's many other Technologies are
being developed these days like awesome
CGI or some robotics I think the future
holds something really cool in a sense
of learning about animals without the
detriment of keeping them in captivity
virtual reality with Wildlife encounters
is really coming on taking a virtual
walk through a herd of elephants in the
Serengeti I think is going to be
possible pretty soon
[Music]
if you think that it should exist
it's kind of strange that we transport
all of these animals from far from home
and keep them locked up where you should
see what Nature has to offer on your
doorstep
Wildlife documentary virtual reality
none of these things have the same
positive emotional impact that a zoo has
10 of the global population visit zoos
every year people from all walks of life
and all social classes so I think
without zoos we lose a massive
opportunity to keep people being
interested in the wild environment
foreign
what I'm hoping is that we can design
super sustainable cities so that you
don't need to go to a place to see
animals they're all around you
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video